ah
a
el golpe de estado supone un grave
contratiempo para pekín primero porque
ha echado al gobierno democrático de
ansa en su kiko en el que había
mantenido unas relaciones mucho mejores
que con los militares y también porque
ha sumido al país en un grave clima de
inestabilidad que pone en peligro sus
inversiones y que la obligado a reforzar
las fronteras para impedir la entrada
masiva de birmanos que huyen de la
violencia pero china está presa por su
principio sagrado de no intervención en
asuntos externos lo que le empuja a
tratar con todo tipo de gobiernos de
gusten más o le gusten menos y eso le
está pasando factura primero en
cuestiones de imagen global y segundo
porque los manifestantes han atacado
algunas de sus fábricas chinas se ha
sumado a la condena de la onu por la
utilización de violencia contra
manifestantes pacíficos pero es dudoso
que vaya a ir más allá y como es
habitual esperar a ver cómo se
desarrollan los hechos sin tomar partido
[Música]
mientras que occidente y sus aliados
asiáticos clave condenan el golpe y han
impuesto sanciones a la junta desde el
principio rusia se ha negado a condenar
el golpe y el ministerio de relaciones
exteriores rusos simplemente expresó su
esperanza en una solución pacífica a la
situación mediante el diálogo medios
públicos rusos justifican incluso el
golpe con el argumento de que el
ejército de mianmar es el único garante
viable de la unidad del país la
manifestación más visible del apoyo ruso
a la junta se produjo a finales del mes
de marzo cuando el ministro de defensa
ruso fue el funcionario extranjero de
más alto rango en asistir al desfile de
las fuerzas armadas de mianmar
moscú señala como una muestra alentadora
que los militares tenían intención de
celebrar unas elecciones parlamentarias
a continuación esto es algo que no le
bastó a moscú por ejemplo en el caso de
las revueltas ucranianas de 2014
[Música]
un grupo bipartidista de senadores
estadounidenses le pidió esta semana a
la administración de jowhar en que
imponga nuevas sanciones a la junta
militar en mianmar sanciones que
incluyen suspender las regalías que
chevron la empresa de petróleo
estadounidense le manda a la empresa
estatal de gas y energía de mianmar y
que termina financiando así las
actividades antidemocráticas de la junta
al ser una de las únicas fuentes de
divisas de este país las ongs de este
país también le han pedido a chevron ya
total
empresas petroleras que rompan todos los
vínculos que tienen con la junta por su
parte el ex presidente barack obama dijo
en sus redes sociales que el esfuerzo de
los militares de imponer su voluntad en
el mar nunca será aceptado y que apoya
los avances de la administración de
bailén en imponer sanciones a los
militares para fomentar el regreso a la
democracia
recordemos que en febrero de este año
eeuu incluso sanciones y pidió a los
países cercanos a hacer lo mismo para
presionar el retorno a la democracia en
mianmar
a los prisioneros políticos
[Música]